now the labor leaders kirst armor will
set out his vision for a labor
government later on today in his first
speech of the year he's expected to say
that labor is no longer the party of big
spending vowing that he would not get
its big government checkbook out again
well this comes a day after Michigan
sunac made his own speech about
priorities for the year ahead so let's
hear a little bit more about all of this
the shadow Chancellor Rachel Reeves is
with me now so Rachel Reeves we're told
that today's speech from secure starmer
will be all about what he stands for so
what does kirst armor stand for
good morning Anna it's great to be on
your program this morning at Kia's
speech today we'll be setting out uh
some of the the vision for a labor
leadership and a labor government and
particularly focusing on the fact that
our country seems to Lurch from crisis
to crisis with sticking plaster policies
to paper over the cracks rather than
addressing some of the long-term
challenges that we face as a country and
that is what Kira is determined to do as
our next prime minister to actually get
a grip of some of the long-term
underlying problems with our health
service with our economy with our energy
Supply and so much more to put us on a
thermo footing to make us more resilient
and more secure as a society and as an
economy to face into the big challenges
and Kira and myself runs a No Illusion
about the scale of the challenges that
we will inherit so a big set of
challenges but we are ambitious for the
country we see so much potential and we
want to unleash that to to Really secure
better public services and also
improvements in living standards that
frankly people haven't seen for a decade
or more
well the government Richie sunak would
no doubt say that they're also tackling
those long-term challenges and just
yesterday we heard from the Prime
Minister didn't we he says he's putting
forward some concrete promises on that
front those five pledges on debt jobs
waiting lists and small boats the things
that he says are people's main
priorities are those labor priorities
too
well look everybody wants to see
um waiting lists come down Small Boat
Crossings uh uh end but the the Prime
Minister yesterday uh has announced a
set of
um Ambitions to fix the problems that
him and his government have created and
then wants the public to give him the
credit for doing that I just don't think
it washes the conservatives have had 13
years now and the question that people
will be asking is uh my family and me
better off after 13 years of
conservative government are our public
services our schools and our hospitals
are better run and in better condition
than they were 13 years ago and frankly
is anything in our country working
better than it was when the
conservatives came to power and I think
the answer to those questions is no and
that's why people are turning away from
the conservatives and looking again at
Labor and for the first time in quite a
long time I think labor can look to the
country knowing that we have the answers
the fully costed and funded policies to
address some of the long-term big
challenges that we face as a country and
give people some hope back and some
belief back that things can be better
than the mess that we've been in these
last few years
okay you want to give people hope back
the last time we heard from kirstama was
a speech with Gordon Brown on Devolution
which may be important but it may not
necessarily be something you put on a
pledge card it may not be something that
may give people hope so are we going to
get new policies today
well look when I'm in in my constituency
in Leeds and I'll be there this evening
when I travel around the country people
have huge ambition and pride in their
communities and they want a government
that matches that ambition and that
Pride but also empowers local people and
Community to take decisions on their
behalf rather than always having to come
cap in hand to the government to ask
them for money and for support and
resources to to power their communities
we want to give power to local people
and local communities to make decisions
on their own behalf to realize the
potential of their communities and
that's why the plans that KIA put
forward at the end of last year to
devolve more power to give away more
power to to Regions and Nations and
communities across Britain it is so
exciting because For the first time in a
long time local people will be able to
make decisions on their behalf rather
than having to ask government to be able
to do things whether it's on buses or
trains or transport or energy or housing
actually make those decisions for
themselves okay so we're going to hear
more about evolution is what you're
saying what about new policies will we
get anything new from kirst armor today
well look you'll you hear the speech and
Care we'll set that out but the key
theme in the speech today is that we
need to tackle the long-term challenges
that our country faces because while
every country in the world has been
exposed to shocks from covid to Russia's
invasion of Ukraine we in Britain have
been uniquely exposed we ran down our
Health Service we ran down our PPE
supplies and so we were ill-prepared for
the covid pandemic but we got rid of our
gas storage we banned on short wind and
we stopped our home insulation program
which meant that we were exposed to
increases in gas and electricity prices
we can't keep lurching from crisis to
crisis we need Labor's green Prosperity
plan to ensure that we have energy
security and Independence while keeping
prices low we need to reform our health
service but also resource it properly
with one of the biggest expansions of
the workforce in history funded by
getting rid of the non-dom tax status so
that we can afford more doctors and
nurses and midwives and health visitors
those are just some of the policies that
labor will be setting out in more detail
over the next year that can make us
stronger as an economy stronger as a
society more resilient to the shocks
that face not just Britain but around
the world but for which Britain has been
particularly exposed to because of the
neglect from the conservatives
so you want to boost the number of
doctors you say you're going to fund
that from Banning London status but what
about day-to-day spending on the NHS
kirstama we're told will say that his
pledges shouldn't be taken as code for
getting the checkbook out so does that
mean that the NHS will get no more money
beyond what was promised in the Autumn
statement
well we've set out how we would get rid
of the non-dom tax status which costs
3.2 billion pounds a year and we would
plow that money into training more
doctors and nurses because one of the
big problems that we've got is of
retention and recruitment in our
National Health Service which means
every day of the week not just when
there's industrial action it's a real
challenge to get that doctor's
appointment to be seen at a e to get an
ambulance when you need it and get a bed
in a hospital and so we've committed to
that expansion of doubling the number of
places every year at medical school as
well as expansions of Midwife District
nurses and and nurses training places as
well to uh to and we know that these
things won't happen overnight and we
know that it takes time to train doctors
and nurses but under labor the Cavalry
is coming we will invest in the
workforce in the NHS we also know that
more is needed this winter and if we
were in power to day we would be doing
more to ensure that people could be
discharged from hospital because our
social care system would be working uh
better we'll be reforming doctors
pensions so that doctors aren't taking
early retirement because it just doesn't
Stack Up financially for them to
continue
um at work we would introduce Fair pay
agreements for our social care sector to
help Recruitment and Retention there and
we would launch a Jabs Army to uh to to
get people to be administering as we had
during the covid pandemic the Jabs for
covid and flu to help people ensure that
they're properly protected through these
winter months because we know more and
more beds are being taken up in our
hospitals because of people with flu and
covered so we need to make sure that
that vaccination program for both flu
and covet are being properly rolled out
but look it's really important that
every policy that labor puts forward is
fully costed and fully funded it's what
the electorate expect from us and it
shows a respect for the Etc that we show
where the money is going to come from
and every line in our Manifesto will be
fully costed and fully funded we've said
that we would get rid of the non-dom tax
status and use that to fund our National
Health Service I think that's the right
priority for our economy and for our
country okay Rachel Reese we appreciate
your time this morning thanks so much